[Music]
mike is with us mike is in lexington hey
mike how are you
hi dave and rachel thank you for taking
my call sure what's up um
i've got a 529 that i started for my
daughter years ago
and now my daughter is older and has
pretty much disowned me
um
what should i do
what should i do with that 529 since i
don't see any
uh
future reconnection with my with my
daughter
i'm sorry
that's awful
um
how old how old is she
she's 16. it's due to
parent manipulation
yeah oh i'm sorry mike
um
well you you how much is in there
uh 16 grand okay
uh i can give you the legal technical
answer
um
the legal technical answer is the money
is hers it's in her name
and you put yourself in the seat of the
manager of her money
and you have a legal responsibility to
manage her money for her
and it the
the setup doesn't account for
relationship one way or the other
okay okay and so it's her money
uh you don't have a choice in that
technically
um
now uh on a practical level
if you cash it out um you're probably
gonna have some taxes on it a little bit
um
and it doesn't sound to me like
anybody's gonna bother you
but you'd hypothetically could get sued
later
if uh that you stole her money or
something you know that kind of thing uh
so
i'm not suggesting you do that i'm just
telling you that it's 16 000 bucks it's
not it's not 1.6 million
so um but uh vindictive
kids from manipulative parents uh in a
split up situation you never know so i
don't know what you do with it it's up
to you
um
what i i i assume you've got this with a
a financial advisor right
no not yet
okay who's the who's the 529 with
it's it's through
our state
it's not through a financial advisor
okay you might contact them and ask them
if you can transfer
the custodianship
to her mom
in other words take your name off of the
responsibility line
and transfer the line of responsibility
to her mom and then her mom is in charge
of the money
uh for her until she's 21 like you're in
charge of the money for her until she's
21 right now
and that would get you out of the
loop
um that's probably the cleanest thing
you can do do you have other kids mike
no it's just a single daughter okay but
you don't have children with another
marriage or anything else
no sir okay
all right
um
yeah i mean i'm just trying i'm trying i
i can't get past the
the knot i have in my throat from just
the whole idea of this but
um but but aside from that the practical
thing is
if you get it out of your
otherwise you are are bound to resp you
know to manage this for her for her
education
and um i guess she has to come to you
for that then if you want to leave it
there as bait
you can
right well even if
even if
i were to
remove that money
through my disability with the military
she's still
you know i'd still cover her for
a portion of
the tuition for any you still can
you still can
but you're not required to
okay the military benefit doesn't
require it and she can't access it
without going through you the military
benefit or the 529.
so how long have you all been split up
you and the x
oh me and the x have been split for
11 years now okay and how how long has
your daughter
made the decision that she doesn't want
to contact with you
about a year okay
um
can i change hats
i'm just gonna be dad
um
i wouldn't do anything
i would just let her mother know and i
would write her some letters they may or
may not get through to her just telling
her how much you love her
and that you're here and then when she
gets ready to call to college there's a
college fund and that there's a military
benefit and all she's got to do is get
in contact with you and you'll be happy
to help her with that
and i would just let that lay there
yeah because she's 16 mike and i'm like
man
she's going to come around i i
i have hope that they're you know what i
mean it's um
that there's still years and obviously
she's still gonna be living i'm assuming
with your ex um to you may not feel like
it's gonna get better but i wonder as
she gets older
um
even 18 19 20 years old do you know what
i mean what what matures in her and her
curiosity towards you all of it you know
she still feels still young even though
it's it's extremely beautiful what was
your relationship with her before all
this
uh we had a fairly decent relationship
she'll
did something happen mike was there an
event that happened or just over time
she was like i just want anything to do
with you
i believe it was over time okay
there wasn't a set blow up where you did
something
no so okay i'm gonna let this and the
military benefit lay there because she's
gonna come back around and you're gonna
be able to bless her and it's gonna be
part of the reconciliation story
okay
that's papa dave talking that's not a
legal financial answer
but it's also correct by the way it's
also legal and it's also financial but
um
um and you know she's got to come
through you to get to that and if she
wants to go to school completely
debt-free you've got a military benefit
and she has a college fund that you
funded for and you love her and and
anytime you want to talk i'm here to
talk and
anything you want to you know yell at me
about you can yell at me about and
you get ready to go to school i'm gonna
i'm in a position to help you just get
in touch with me at that time and
more than that i want a relationship
with you you know absolutely above and
beyond just absolutely right now that's
the whole point but yeah i think you
just sit with these things and
but and hold them in your hands and
they're an opportunity to bless her as
the reconciliation goes along and um uh
and it's it you know there's just a
natural gravitational pull between a
daughter and her dad unless there's
something really toxic and really wrong
and um okay i um
i've watched it with friends over the
years uh where there's a temporary
shutdown that felt like it was permanent
and they come back around and
they really do fair way of figuring out
the truth
sometimes it just takes a little while
i'm sorry